we've all heard the argument that we
should be vegetarian to reduce our
individual carbon footprints food makes
up around a quarter of global greenhouse
gas emissions and meat in particular has
a large carbon price tag associated with
it so we're cutting it out of our diets
we would each be emitting fewer harmful
greenhouse gases however if we can't
face being vegetarian but only ate meat
from local farms and that would still be
much better for the climate right to
answer this question we need to look at
the price tag in greenhouse gas
emissions associated with different
kinds of food notice here that I'm
saying greenhouse gas emissions not
carbon emissions because there are other
gases at play methane is significantly
emitted by for example cows but also
bacteria living in rice paddies we can
bundle together the effects of lots of
different polluting gases using the idea
of co2 equivalent emissions this is
effectively the amount of co2 emissions
required to have the same warming impact
on the atmosphere as all the gases that
you've lumped together so methane for
example is a potent greenhouse gas on
short timescales so one tonne of methane
emissions is 25 tons of co2 equivalent
emissions so one ton of methane emitted
with one ton of co2 would be 26 tons of
co2 equivalent emissions you get the
idea
in a study in 2018 poor and nemecheck
analyzed the co2 equivalent emissions
are lots of different foodstuffs ranging
from beef and chicken right the way to
apples and oranges and then they
compared them the crucial thing to know
is that the author is considered what's
called the lifetime emissions of these
foods so all the emissions associated
with a kilo of a particular food that
includes how you change the landscape to
produce it how you grow it process it
transport it and ultimately package and
sell it it's all the greenhouse gases
emitted over the lifetime of a foodstuff
from farm to fork I've taken a selection
of foodstuffs and broken down their
lifetime emissions in co2 equivalent
kilograms into these different processes
so let's go through them first of all
how you change the land to produce the
foodstuff beef and surprisingly
chocolate are big emitters right out of
the gates on this one chocolate
presumably because of the high dairy
content and cows require big pastures
then let's add on the emissions
associated with the feed given to
farmyard animals emissions from
fertilizers farm machinery deep animal
themselves and other processes
associated with growing the food and for
good measure let's also check on the
emissions associated with processing
already we can see that beef is heard
and shoulders above all other types of
food powerful pound it has the largest
carbon footprint and other meat products
are similarly high though of all of them
poultry is the lowest and at the other
end of the spectrum you have plant-based
foods such as rice tomatoes bananas
however just wait let's now add on the
emissions associated with transports
both nationally and internationally and
see how much of a difference the food
miles make as you can see it's a
seriously small effect transport makes
up on average less than 10% of the
lifetime greenhouse gas emissions of
most foodstuffs and for beef it's just
not 0.5% when we add on the final
contribution to the lifetime emissions
of food that associated with retail and
with packaging you can see just how
little an impact the food miles of a
food has on its total carbon footprint
but how can that be some foods like
avocados must have huge transport costs
as after all they're flown in from the
other side of the world only to meet
that ignominiously influences toast not
me
by the way do you have an Instagram
which you should follow but I don't like
avocados they're trash and Nestor and
guacamole fight me nerds
well actually very very little food is
transported by plane for a nemecheck
report that food transport by planes
only accounts for point 1 6 percent of
all food miles 60 percent of food miles
are via water and shipping is 50 times
less polluting in terms of greenhouse
gases than plane the shipping is
actually very carbon efficient so most
of the foods that you think of is being
very exotic and likely flown in are
probably taken by boat for what it's
worth the foods that are airlifted tend
to be highly perishable things like
berries and asparagus things with short
shelf lives if these are grown far from
where you live then avoiding them will
make something of a difference to your
carbon footprint via food miles but by
buying local meat how much are you
reducing your personal carbon footprint
according to one study conducted in the
EU by the most 6% of your total food
footprint if instead you were to cut out
all dairy and meat and eggs from your
diet so go vegan then according to that
same study
you would reduce your food footprint by
83% I'm not advocating that everyone
should become vegan although it
definitely would be better for the
environment if everyone did and I myself
am only vegetarian for what it's worth I
don't miss eating meat apart from sweaty
kebabs and I don't view it as a hardship
at all my diet has definitely improved
by turning veggie the point I'm trying
to get across is that buying local meat
reducing your food miles makes only a
tiny dent in your personal carbon
footprint don't be fooled into thinking
that you've made a significant
contribution to the fight against
climate change by doing so if you want
to actually reduce your personal carbon
footprint then you need to reduce the
amount of meat and dairy you're eating
this doesn't have to be all the way you
could for example eating meat just on
the weekends or just give up beef as
we've seen it's by far the worst emitter
but just eating local meats for local
people
I'm afraid isn't gonna cut it what else
can we do as individuals about climate
change well I've made a whole video
about that and also about how individual
action isn't enough and another about
what you maybe shouldn't do links in the
end screen that's actually it for this
video I just wanted to do a quick one
today answering this common question if
you enjoyed it definitely check out my
other videos on climate they're linked
in the description and on the end screen
this video was largely based on an
excellent article on art world in data
which is linked below I've basically
just animated a bunch of figures from it
and filled in some gaps check it out if
you'd like to learn more from a
fantastic source thank you for watching
and I'll see you in the next one well
you won't because I'm not gonna be
appearing on camera until I can get a
bloody haircut seriously I look like the
bassist from Guitar Hero 3